[Musique]
monsieur s'il vous plaît vous le pensez
j'ai pensé à la saint-valentin rayant up
sur wii le fait souvent par souvent
depuis longtemps de la première fois je
m'excuse mais vous êtes peut-être
amoureux oui comme il se doit
et à votre avis est ce que beaucoup de
vos camarades le font parce que j'ai
l'impression sais pas s'il ya beaucoup
qu'il vous ne me crois que chacun doit
le faire un moment de sa vie toujours
j'en ai un peu exceptionnel pour les
fleuristes aujourd'hui la vitesse a
maintenant s'intéresser plus d'amour oui
est ce que ça marche rien n'est pas
beaucoup
pourquoi risquer d'être chaud et les
faire le supporter cet enfant est ce que
chaque année quand même la saint
valentin le monde est plus fort que
d'habitude non alors il ya plus
d'amoureux paris est une fête qui a du
mal à partir
comment ça se fait ça
avec afp
fabien romeyer
cette terre santé
la saint-valentin contre le tiers
provisionnel et malgré tout quand même
les quelques amoureux qui viennent
qu'est ce qu'ils achètent comme fleurs
de préférence
j'ai rendu aujourd'hui quelques cousins
aller
et la violette ça se fait plus pas
tellement
monsieur ce que vous êtes venus pour la
saint-valentin acheter des fleurs
non c'est plutôt bon et de votre temps
est ce que on fêtait aussi la saint
valentin
j'en ai pas de souvenance rapport les
quantités d'années et s'est fait plus
c'était pas la mode bon monsieur je
m'excuse mais vous avez amoureux sont
neutres on complète un fait si loin que
je me rappelle est ce que vous achetiez
des fleurs quand même votre fiancée à
l'époque fera au début qui était marié
oui et après après sa c4 mais vu les
événements et on a voulu faire de la
saint valentin alors on a était tombée
la saint valentin en ascenseur
malheureusement qu elle l a fait que
nous célébrons aujourd'hui
puis c'est le simple saint valentin
saint valentin mais vous n'êtes pas
d'ici peut-être non badiou anglais sans
doute oui oui est-ce qu en angleterre il
ya une fête qui ressemble à saint
valentin
oui mais ce n'est pas le même chose
complètement c c'est à dire c'est à dire
que le centre longtemps en anglais en
angleterre on voit les cartes mais des
progrès au cg on doit faire envoyer des
cartes que des fleurs en anglais
brillant c'est cela oui mais venir une
pop a signé les cas
savez vous quelle est la fête que nous
célébrons aujourd'hui en france baj vous
n'avez pas n'ai pas regardé le
calendrier nous apprenons que c'est la
saint valentin ça vous dit rien si ça
fait des amoureux enfin c'est tout ce
que vous savez c'est oui on avait pensé
à vous aujourd'hui non vous ne pensez
pas servez les hommes de maintenant faut
compter le manga dont ils pensent tous
très bien ainsi désavoué c'était une
conclusion merci
[Musique]